turns out we have not seen the end of  football at sam boyd stadium  starting tomorrow the university of new  mexico football team is going to start  practicing at the old venue on the east  side of the valley  players and staff are going to live at  unlv student housing and then attend  classes at new mexico remotely  new mexico's coronavirus restrictions  keep the lobos from practicing and  playing over there  so new mexico is going to play here the  lobos first game is going to be saturday  at hawaii but then they're expected to  hold their november 14th game  against unr here in las vegas the wolf  pack coming back to southern nevada